What if you could use genetic engineering
to stop humanity's most dangerous
Predator,
the deadliest animal on the planet
responsible for the death of billions,
the mighty mosquito along
with other diseases.
It plays host to malaria,
one of the cruelest parasites on earth,
possibly the single biggest killer
of humans in history. In 2015 alone,
hundreds of millions were infected
and almost half a million people died.
A new technology could help us
eradicate malaria forever, but to do so,
we need to engineer a
whole animal population.
This is not a hypothetical problem.
The modified mosquitoes
already exists in a lab.
Should we use the technology and
is malaria bad enough to risk it?
Malaria is caused by a
group of microorganisms,
plasmodium very weird microorganisms
that consist of justice,
single cell, that parasites that
completely rely on mosquitoes.
Malaria always starts with an
insect bite and its salivary glands.
Thousands of sporozoites wait until the
insect penetrates your skin immediately
after invading you the head for the
liver where they quietly and to big cells
and hide from the immune
system for up to a month.
They stay here in stealth mode,
consuming the cells alive and
changing into their next form.
Small drop like neuroscience.
They multiply generating thousands of
themselves and then burst out of the cells
so thousands of parasites head into
the bloodstream to look for their next
victims,
red blood cells to stay unnoticed.
They wrap themselves in the
membranes of the cells they killed.
Imagine that killing someone from the
inside and then taking their skin that has
camouflage brutal.
They now violently attack red blood
cells multiplying inside them until they
burst. Then finding more red blood cells
and this cycle repeats over and over.
Pieces of dead cells spread lots of
toxic waste material which activates a
powerful immune response
causing flu like symptoms.
Among the symptoms are high fever, sweats
and chills, convulsions, headaches,
and sometimes vomiting and diarrhea. If
malaria breaches the blood brain barrier,
it can cause coma,
neurological damage or death.
The parasites are ready for evacuation.
Now when another mosquito bites the
infected human, they get a ride.
The cycle can start over
in 2015 the Zika virus,
which causes horrible birth defects
if it infects pregnant women,
spread rapidly into new areas around the
globe. It too is carried by a mosquito.
The mosquito is the perfect
carrier for human diseases.
They've been around for at
least 200 million years.
There are trillions of them and a
single one can they up to 300 at a time.
They are practically impossible to
eradicate and the perfect parasite taxi.
But today we have a new revolutionary
technology that could enable us to finally
win the war against them. Crispr
for the first time in human history,
we have the tools to make fast large
scale changes to entire species changing
their genetic information as we please.
So instead of attacking
isolated groups of insects,
why not just change the
types that transmit diseases?
Using genetic engineering?
Scientists successfully created a strain
of mosquitoes that are immune to the
malaria parasite by adding a new
antibody gene that specifically targets
plasmodium. These mosquitoes
will never spread malaria,
but just changing genetic
information is not enough.
The edits would only be inherited by half
the offspring because most jeans have
two versions inside the genome as a fail
safe. So after just two generations,
at most, only half of the offspring
would carry the engineer gene.
In a population of billions of mosquitoes,
they would hardly make a difference.
A genetic engineering method called
the gene drive solves this problem.
It forces the new gene to become
dominant in the following generations.
Overpowering the old gene almost
completely thanks to this twist.
99.5% of all the engineered mosquitoes
offspring will carry the anti malaria
adis.
If we were to release enough engineered
mosquitoes into the wild to mate with no
mosquitoes, the malaria blocking
genes would spread extremely quickly.
As the new gene becomes a permanent
feature of the mosquito population,
plasmodium would lose its home base.
Scientists hope that the change would be
so fast that they could not adapt to it
quickly enough.
Malaria could virtually disappear.
If you take into account that maybe
half a million children are killed by it
every year. About five have
died since this video started.
Some scientists argue that we should use
the technology sooner rather than later.
The mosquitoes themselves would
probably only profit from this.
They don't have anything to gain from
carrying parasites and this might only be
the first step.
Malaria might just be the beginning.
Different mosquitoes also carried daggy
fever and Zika ticks transmit Lyme
disease. Flyers transmits sleeping
sickness, fleas transmit the plague.
We could save millions of
lives and prevent suffering
on an unbelievable scale.
So why haven't we done this yet?
For one,
CRISPR editing is batty four years old,
so until very recently we just couldn't
do it as fast and easily and there are
valid concerns.
Never before have humans consciously
change the genetic code of a free living
organism on this scale. Once we
do it, there is no going back,
so we're,
it has to be done right because there
could be unwanted consequences if we set
out to edit nature.
In the specific case of malaria though
the risk be acceptable since the genetic
modification doesn't make a big change
in the overall genome is only changes a
very specific part.
The worst case scenario here is probably
that it might not work or that the
parasite adapts in a negative way.
There is still much debate technology
as powerful as gene drive needs to be
handled with a lot of care, but at
some point we have to ask ourselves,
is it unethical to not use this technology
when every day 1000 children die?
Humanity has to decide how to act
on this in the next few years.
The public discussion is way behind
the technology. In this case,
what do you think
this video was made possible in
part by viewer donations on Patrion?
If you want to help us make more videos
like this and get nice rewards in return,
you can do so here.
We really appreciate it.
If you want to learn more about
the topic of genetic engineering,
we have another video
about CRISPR and Gmos,
and in case that's too much biology
for you. Here's a space pay list.